[Musik]
sie rufen Ruhm den Helden und sie sehen
unendlich glücklich und unendlich
traurig aus wenn man sich fragt wie ein
Ende dieses Krieges einmal daherkommen
könnte dann vielleicht so mit
heimkehrenden Einheiten wie diesen
Ukrainerinnen freigelassen aus
russischer Gefangenschaft es ist Anfang
der Woche es ist saporizia und es ist
eine diplomatische Lösung das Bild wie
die sogenannte
menschenrechtskommissarin Russlands
ihrem ukrainischen Gegenüber die Hand
gibt verstärkt die Sehnsucht
verhandeln vertragen und an
Vereinbarungen wie diese anknüpfen das
wichtige in der Diplomatie ist dass man
Anknüpfungspunkte hat und diese
Anknüpfungspunkte sind dadurch eben auch
hergestellt und da sollte man schon
befördern die Verhandlungserfolge des
gegeben hat wird danken bei der Ukraine
die haben das verhandelt und um Irland
geht es und deshalb sollten wir engstens
bei bleiben bei zielinsky und bei den
Leuten in der Ukraine bleibt Deutschland
bei den Leuten in der Ukraine oder soll
Berlin soll Brüssel die angegriffenen
Menschen drängen mit den Angreifern zu
verhandeln es gibt Europäer die keinen
anderen Ausweg sehen
mich erinnert die Zeit in der wir uns
bewegen an den Ersten Weltkrieg und alle
dachten dieser Krieg dauert ein paar
Wochen ein paar Monate und dann wurde
das ein kontinentales gemetzelt es steht
die Sorge dass der Krieg sich ausweitet
weil der Westen nicht mit Russland
verhandelt gegen die Sorge dass der
Krieg sich ausweitet weil der Westen mit
Russland verhandelt und sich ein
weiteres Mal von Russland täuschen lässt
leichtfertige Sprüche na ja jetzt
verhandelt doch endlich mal es kommt ja
nicht auf jeden Fall der Ukraine zu
dringend an ich sage sehr klar und
deutlich
diese aus meiner Sicht dann doch naive
Haltung ist schon 2014 gescheitert
anders als 2014 begründet Putin seine
gebietseroberungen nicht mehr nur mit
Sicherheitsinteressen sondern auch mit
dem Kampf gegen Satanismus gegen
Perversionen und gegen westliche
abnoritäten nach diesen Tönen nach
diesen Bildern hat Präsident selenski
Verhandlungen mit Putin untersagt aus
Deutschland kommt eine Ermahnung
es ist notwendig dass man versucht eine
Friedenslösung durch Verhandlungen zu
erreichen und das ein Gegenüber da auch
nicht den eigenen Werten entspricht und
man das nicht gut findet was die Person
sagt das ist normal und das ist in
Verhandlungen auf der Fall aber du
believe wir glauben dass jede Pause
jeder Waffenstillstand dazu führen würde
dass sich die Russische Föderation auf
eine neue Phase der Aggression
vorbereitet sie würden Menschen Waffen
Fahrzeuge sammeln und den Krieg
fortsetzen wir glauben dass wir für
unser Überleben kämpfen müssen
in Deutschland kommt der Ruf nach einem
Kurswechsel vor allem von der Straße er
wird gehört und vertieft die Risse in
der Koalition ich fühle mich da sehr
unterstützt auch zumindest einer
Wahrnehmung in der Bevölkerung die
letzten Meinungsumfragen 60 Prozent die
mehr diplomatische Initiativen wollen
und ich denke mal das auch an die
Adresse der Außenministerin gesagt
worden Annalena baerbock tut alles was
sie kann damit wir zum Frieden kommen
gleichzeitig sagt der Bundeskanzler
völlig zu Recht dass wir bei
Waffenlieferung beispielsweise eng
abgestimmt sein müssen mit unseren
Partnern zu diesen Partnern gehört
unabdinglich auch die Ukraine und der
Kollege Mütze nicht sollte das wissen es
klingt so gut eine diplomatische Lösung
verhandelt wie beim Gefangenenaustausch
die Frage ist ob sie ersonnen oder
erkämpft werden muss